esta es la única vía abierta para
aquellas personas que quieren pasar a
territorio controlado por rusia o que
quieran regresar hacia territorio
controlado por ucrania aquí las personas
por ejemplo desde la playa no pasan 200
coches todos los días hacia el otro lado
maxim y su familia van camino a la
población de enarbolar reconocen que
tienen miedo pero no tienen otra opción
que regresar habíamos venido para
tratamientos en el hospital vamos de
vuelta porque tenemos cosas pendientes
que tenemos que cuidar
en la medida que la caravana avanza el
peligro se hace mayor y pronto quedan en
una zona gris que nadie controla estos
coches vienen ya de territorio ruso el
cruce es a 200 metros de aquí y cuentan
por esta línea la casa que se ve de
techo verde a la distancia a partir de
ahí todo este territorio ya está en
control de las fuerzas rusas y atacan
con frecuencia al territorio ucraniano
donde las fuerzas de este país los
repelen
natalia es una de las 20 personas que
permanecen en cambiante la última
población y control ucraniano
cosas horribles han pasado una caravana
de carros con niños pasaban por aquí lo
atacaron las niñas gritaban se
intentaron esconder es imposible las
explosiones de este lado y del otro
esta pareja se llega a dejar la casa
para pasar la vejez
conversión espiritual y mire el pueblo
está totalmente destruido dormimos en el
sótano vivimos en el sótano entienden lo
que es es un
horror similar es experimentado por
quienes han hecho el camino desde áreas
bajo el control del gobierno en busca
después de esa larga espera que muchas
veces se extiende por días este es el
primer lugar al que llegan esas familias
que huyen de esas regiones que están en
control del gobierno de moscú muchas de
ellas hablan de momentos muy dramáticos
tratando de pasar esa zona gris en la
cual muchas veces son atacados y lynne y
su familia vienen de gerson tuvieron
cinco días en la carretera antes de que
las dejaran avanzar durante los 20
minutos de la zona gris y vamos con las
manos cogidas y agachados pues sobre
nuestras cabezas había fuego cruzado y
débil el viaje entre ambos lados es un
infierno pero cada día hay cientos de
personas dispuestas a padecerlo